welcome to ireland
once upon a time there were two farms
the mount loon farm where rosemary lived
and
right down the road was my farm where my
son anthony
asked his slowly question of the stars
why did you make me so
rosemary muldoon yeah he's sorted
with love there's these green fields and
there's us
whatever that is it holds me here
[Music]
it's not normal i don't care you take
after john kelly and that man was mad as
the full moon
drowned himself he fell in he had a rock
tied to his neck
brush me we're known to each other quite
the while now
would you marry me
are you going to leave the farm to
anthony i don't see a clear path
from where to where from me to you
my cousin is coming really it's the
finest car i've ever seen
enough for the farm to an american ready
for that one
what are you waiting for me i don't wait
i do like that
you should come to new york sometime
anthony will never marry if it comes to
that i'd freeze my eggs it should freeze
your whole body if you're waiting for
that one
[Applause]
you ever had a dream since you were a
child and you couldn't let it go
so you put this gate between us is your
dream made you happy or miserable
you kissed him it was he that kissed me
that's what's gotten worked off
i don't understand you people why do you
make everything so hard you just
seem to accept these crazy things i
don't like your fights
who does half of ireland just not me if
my true love
he were gone i would surely find another
anthony time is running out
what is love is it a quest
what are you doing the madness
how many days do we have while the sun
shines it's not shining
i believe that it is
you